today's the [ __ ] day
it's you and me your box
[Music]
oh no hi my name is grace help if you
don't know now you know your life is
different now
i'm clearly dressed in my best
gardening clothes which only means one
thing today we're turning a goddamn
toilet into a goddamn planter and
there's not a goddamn thing you can do
about it do you like this look how
intimate this video is already that's
what all gardening videos are very
relaxed and intimate and that's the
energy i hope
you experience today because it's
something we all need now if you guys
don't remember
that's fine because memory is just a
complete illusion in the quarantine
ellie and i installed a new toilet in
our bathroom look at it
no that seems too intimate look at it it
still works we did that about
17 years ago which means that i have a
spare toilet out here and the plan
forever has been to turn that toilet
into a planter
and today it's finally happening i don't
know why i've been so hesitant to do it
i think it's just been like such a fun
project in my mind that committing to
doing it means i can mess it up and if i
don't try i don't fail and that's what
we call self-sabotage but not today
why am i nervous because i want to do a
good job for the toilet
safe we overlook toilets but they're the
real heroes and i want to do it justice
you know it's provided me so much that i
want to honor it
feng shui so a while ago i ordered a
bunch of little tiny baby
succulents look at these they're so cute
i want to squeeze them why is that
something that humans think about so
cute i want to call
it drama i don't think i should be a
mother but i have all these tiny little
succulents
and i have a variety of other succulents
i love succulents they look like little
aliens and they're pretty
self-sufficient you can't really hurt
them too much
and i love things that just have a lot
of walls up i have done
next to zero research on the right
way to do this you know when you think
about doing anything there's no real
right way
unless you're talking about driving
childbirth making bread
i guess i don't like to flood my brain
with other people's techniques i like to
try and figure it out for myself that
might also be some form of self-sabotage
but i like to think of it
as allowing myself the opportunity to
creatively problem-solve what i
understand about turning a toilet into a
planter
is you just plant plants in it and the
toilet becomes a planter so that's what
we're gonna do today i'm also whispering
because i don't know why i'm a little
insecure standing outside
of my house where my neighbors can see
me in a top gun onesie
putting plants into a toilet but you
know we're all just you know doing the
best we can so i'm just gonna go for it
but first i'm gonna stand here
and over analyze it and think about all
the ways it could go wrong first that's
the first step
all right let's see this toilet before
its makeover
[Music]
i'm already sweating the next obvious
step is to pose with your toilet
like a lighthearted rom-com or comedy
movie poster
[Music]
so this is what we're working with it's
a little dirty from being outside and
facing
the natural outdoor elements so got all
this stuff in here that i guess i'll
have to
take out plan is to put soil in this guy
and in this guy
and then plant and have a beautiful
piece of confusing art think of this as
like
the makeover montage of the nerdy girl
in like every teen comedy
[Music]
okay i actually had to take a quick
break because i had to pee and i didn't
want
that toilet to know instead i wanted to
give her some time to reflect on the
fact that she's beautiful just the way
she is and we're not changing
any of her core values we're just you
know putting on some fake eyelashes
basically there she is just reflecting
all right let's do this
i'm probably already doing this wrong
but there's nothing you can do to stop
me
all righty she's so beautiful she can
get so many zoom dates
so it's brought to my attention that the
stuff in the top
tank part of the toilet doesn't just pop
out so uh we're gonna have to get a
little bit
more aggressive very symbolic a lot of
us want to hold on to the things
that we don't need anymore that are just
holding us back i really gotta learn to
let go
she's letting go i broke it
turns out when you force change
sometimes it happens
it's also quickly been brought to my
attention that don't have enough soil
this plant's been
dying consistently since i got it which
has been just
a real cool mood to have lingering
around so i think i'm gonna take some of
this soil we're just gonna put this one
over there for now and deal with it
later
my quick self-help guide
i love gardening
[Music]
oh my god you know what i could do with
these hands rail says dallas reference
i'm really proud of it so far okay now
let's clean her up
this is what they must feel like on
queer eye every episode
[Music]
this looks so cool
right this looks so cool oh is that
recording yeah
real reaction it's really cool
yeah there you go did you have any
doubts
it looks really cool yeah you didn't
answer about the doubts though but
that's cool
oh don't look at this
yeah i put her inside my house in my
office who doesn't want a god dang
toilet
in their goddang office
ignore all that wow we did it look at
her she's absolutely gorgeous
got a little bit of a haircut up here
but i figured the smaller succulents
will grow
and fill in the space i'm in love
with this toilet and that's not the
first time that i've said those words
out loud i hope this video inspired you
to think out of the box in quarantine
you can really make anything out of
anything this is a big old bm
beautiful moment i guess i have a knack
for finding the beauty and things
that are full of on that note i have to
thank cara for sponsoring this video
in line with things like crafting and
diy projects that we're all doing
to better ourselves care of is another
way that you can help better yourself
because it's someone that doesn't treat
their body
the best hence probably why there's an
excess of toilets
in my house i can use all the help i can
get
on efficiently attempting to better my
body if you're not familiar cara this
wellness brand
that makes it easy for you to maintain
health goals
by helping you in the vitamin and
supplement departments
basically you go to their website you
take a super easy online quiz
and then they help you find the vitamins
and the powders that are best for
you once you take the quiz and you
approve all the vitamins and supplements
that you feel are right for you they
send you these little individual vitamin
packs look at that
how freaking cute is that you can take
them on the go with you when you're
allowed to go on the go again and they
have a new skin and hair collection
there's targeted ingredients for your
skin
your hair and your nails we definitely
need some help on our nails
after today look how long my hair has
gotten it looks actually kind of healthy
even though i've had no professional
help with it
since december you didn't hear that and
you can follow their recommendations or
you can adjust them
to personalize it just for you at any
point super easy and now you guys can
get
fifty percent off your first care of
order fifty five 00
off by going to takecareof.com and
entering the code
graceh50 again you can get 50
off your first order 5 0 by going to
takecareof.com
using the code graceh500
perfect anyway thank you guys for
watching this video if you like to give
it a thumbs up this has been a long time
coming i was very nervous about doing it
because i didn't want to do it bad and i
think we did it good and i'm just very
excited about it if you guys like this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
this youtube channel i make videos you
know
you actually don't know what i'm gonna
make videos and that's the fun about
subscribing
is that it's truly like a a gamble and
who doesn't need more uncertainty in
their world
right now i don't know i'm worried
that people are going to like you more
than me oh wait forgot something
she's all that